So now, I want us to start looking deeper.
And start looking at these images and
start seeing what are the numeric values at each and every pixel.
And what in different may, ways, what representation do they have?
And how can you actually start doing these simple types of computations on it?
Here I'm showing a simple image of the mandrill image, the original image here.
And to help us kind of look into it,
I'm going to actually start zooming into it very closely.
And start showing you exactly the details that actually would be seen if you
were actually that close up to that image, but
also start showing you the numerical values associated with an image like this.
So here you note, I've actually put a small red box inside this image.
This is a small red box about, eight pixels by eight pixels or
something like that.
again, I'm showing you pictorial representations of it.
Look at it more of an exercise of looking at how these types of images, and
what kind of information that we have in these images, less of the exact values.
This is just now me showing a zoomed in version with the red region is.
The next one I'll show you exactly what the red region looks like,
namely this one.
Now if you notice here there is a lot of white area and
a little bit of a grayish area and kind of a, a dividing line between them,
which is kind of where you would see the details of this.
And you can see this in much more closeup here now.
Of course, what you also should be seeing if the your display supports it,
a little bit of blockiness in generated pixel.
Again, because these are pixels that we have zoomed in and
gotten really close to.
If i had some magic, and
of course I do when I actually look at it computationally.
I would been able to look at this image and not actually be able to look at
this image but the values that exist in each and every pixel.
Let me zoom into exactly the level of the red pixel region that we have.
And now if you notice, you should be seeing some numbers.
And you notice the numbers are like 159, 168 and
then lower numbers like 131, 132 here.
And approximately there is a little bit of a you know, the same kind of
thing here, where I have white values and a little bit of more gray values.
Now again, this is just simply a pictorial way of looking at it.
These numbers are not exact, even though I've attempted to match it as
closely as possible to this sub image here.
A couple of things we can start doing now.
And that is, start looking at this image a little bit more carefully and
see what we can learn about different intensities and different directions.
So here what I've done is, I've actually now drawn a line.
Basically what I've done is remembering these are our different columns,
and in this there are different rows.
I found one row, I've drawn this, and
I've actually drawn a plot, of the values at that slice.
And if you now traverse it, so
I'm going to start kind of moving it from this way, and if you notice,
there are lots of darker values, of course, there is a lot of change going on,
and all of a sudden, when you come up here, there's a lot more higher values.
Remember, that lower values kind of designate more of the darker shades of
gray or black, and
the brighter values are much more lighter shades of gray towards white.
So white comes in, and here again you see a little bit of change, but now this
actually starts telling us a lot more about this image, just for that one slice.
I also wanted to show that the same slicing can be done in the y axis.
So, here, for example, we have looked at the one row, just one row.
And if you look at it again, the same kind of stuff if you come in from the top
there's a lot of kind of various dark values.
All of a sudden we see a lot more white values.
And again, coming down to a lot more gray values.
So this basically now starts saying we can start looking at these numbers.
Even though the image is shown to us in this form or
this form, there are, underneath it, these values.
And these are extremely important values for us, and
we can actually kind of start doing various types of visualizations of this, and
these basically are just looking at the slices.
So looking at this now, you should be seeing that basically we've kind of
looked at an image, been able to visualize it x and y slices.
This should start suggesting, and especially looking at this this is basically.
This is a two-dimensional representation where each and
every point is basically a pixel, which has its own intensity value.
So the best way to represent this would be a matrix.
This already kind of looks like a matrix.
It's a two dimensional array.
And each and every element of this matrix is a pixel and
the value of that is basically the intensity value there.
So an image can be therefore represented as a matrix.
And the variance of all the vary, the values vary from zero, which is for
black, to 255 which is white.
So this is a scale that goes from 255 to 0, 0 being pure black,
that is no pixel is actually now showing any intensity whatsoever.
And white, where the entire pixel is basically showing
the maximum intensity that is pure white.
Of course, anywhere in between would be different shades of gray